for years the tech industry has been
claiming that robots will be delivering
packages any day now delivery service
using autonomous drones to deliver goods
with flying drones taking a nice robot
for a walk and it's been nearly 10 years
since jeff bezos announced amazon drone
delivery new half hour delivery half
hour delivery half hour delivery well
since that bezos clip he's grown his net
worth from a measly 25 billion to over
200 billion and we still don't have
drones delivering our packages so what
gives jeff
he clearly has the money to do it so why
hasn't it happened is robotic delivery
pure hype or could we actually see this
take off in the next few years to get to
the bottom of this i dug into dozens of
different projects that are working on
this problem and found some really
strange things
let's start with the amazon drone
delivery program and then go into the
more advanced projects after that
although there were other companies
talking about using drones to deliver
small packages before bezos made his
announcement it was the amazon program
that really brought mainstream attention
to the idea dji had just launched the
phantom quadcopter and for the first
time drones were no longer just for
nerds who were willing to solder
different parts together tons of people
were getting drones for christmas and
they were remarkably easy to use every
few months a new drone would come out
with more capabilities and usually it
would be cheaper too using drones to
deliver packages seemed like the next
logical step so in 2013 amazon launched
their prime air division which was
focused on developing all of the
necessary technology to enable this new
delivery method dji drones made for
great toys and could take some pretty
solid video as well but there was no way
that amazon was going to build its new
drone delivery business on top of a
consumer drone platform instead amazon
would need to figure out how to build a
new delivery drone that could fly
completely autonomously then make sure
it didn't break down in bad weather and
finally figure out how to manufacture
millions of them it wouldn't be easy but
bezos had billions of dollars at his
disposal and clearly believed that this
was the future overnight there were tons
of questions about the program was it
safe to have heavy packages flying
around the sky would these drones
contribute to noise pollution and would
this interfere with planes or
helicopters these are reasonable
questions and in order to answer them
amazon would have to deal with the
united states federal aviation
administration or faa see the faa had
already been dealing with a number of
incidents involving drones before bezos
announced his plans to launch millions
more drones had gotten so cheap that
random people could basically fly them
anywhere they wanted to so the faa
cracked down and mandated that drones
fly no higher than 400 feet no faster
than 100 miles per hour and remain
within the pilot's line of sight
additionally these new drone delivery
programs would have to submit
applications to the faa before they
began service to prove that they were
safe amazon's a huge company though so
these regulations weren't too much of an
issue and bezos was able to complete the
first drone delivery to an actual
customer in 2016. it was another big
moment in the press but since then there
hasn't been much development and just a
few months ago wired reported that the
project was winding down after failing
to gain traction big companies fail to
deliver on new technologies all the time
but that doesn't mean that we won't see
drone delivery become commonplace soon
there are plenty of other entrepreneurs
working on the problem and everyone is
taking a slightly different approach
amazon was in a tough situation because
they had to consider every possible
delivery location some people live in
houses surrounded by trees some
neighborhoods have lots of power lines
to worry about designing a
one-size-fits-all solution is incredibly
difficult so most smaller companies have
tried to find workarounds there's a
startup named flirty that's been working
on drone delivery since 2013 and they
use a retractable line to drop the
package to the ground this keeps the
drone safe from obstacles and allows
them to land in different locations it's
a bit of a weird idea but in some areas
it could make a lot of sense flirty's
drone delivery service still isn't
widely available but they've run some
food delivery tests and are continuing
to work with the us government to get
regulatory approval another startup
named matternet actually sets up
dedicated takeoff and landing stations
everywhere that they operate now this is
obviously a bit of a restriction on the
service since it means that the drones
can only deliver between specific
locations but matternet is focused on
medical deliveries so they really only
need to set up one station at each
hospital to enable their service it's
pretty far from the original vision of
ubiquitous drone delivery but if
matternet can solve the core problem of
point-to-point drone delivery between
hospitals they could potentially expand
services from there and medical
deliveries are a really interesting use
case for drones zipline is one of the
most successful startups in this area
and they got their start by delivering
blood donations in rwanda people tend to
think that america is always the best
place to launch a new technology but
that couldn't be further from the truth
growing a drone delivery company is
actually easier in rwanda than america
for a few reasons first demand for this
service is incredibly high moving blood
from central donation centers out to
rural hospitals is incredibly difficult
through normal means in rwanda there
just isn't enough blood to store extra
donations at every single hospital in
the country and driving blood around
just isn't feasible in a life or death
situation
where every second matters zipline's
drone deliveries save lives and that's
led to the rwandan government actually
supporting the initiative and speeding
up regulatory approvals building a new
technology like drone delivery requires
honing in on the highest value use case
and building out from there zipline is
now expanding to other markets but by
starting with blood delivery they were
able to test out the basic technology
before scaling it so it seems like we're
pretty close to getting life-saving
medical supplies delivered by drone in
the near future but what if i just want
a pizza delivered quickly and cheaply
well college students eat a lot of pizza
and there's a different kind of drone
delivery company that's having a lot of
success on college campuses instead of
dealing with the complexities of flying
a quadrotor drone around starship
robotics has focused on building robots
that just drive on the sidewalk
obviously there are some pros and cons
to this approach first off you can drive
these robots basically anywhere that a
human can walk this is great for college
campuses that are designed with
pedestrians in mind most of the
sidewalks are paved and handicapped
accessible although these starship
robots can hop a curb if they need to
more importantly on a college campus
there is a very high density of
potential customers thousands of
students are ready to use the service
and are already familiar with ordering
things online it's also easy to create a
high resolution 3d map of the entire
campus so the robots know exactly where
to go it's not a completely controlled
environment but it's a bit more
forgiving than busy city streets
sticking to small campuses also means
that it's easier to keep the robots from
getting vandalized there's a long
history of tech companies putting things
on the sidewalk and just hoping that
everyone will behave but that's usually
not what happens if starship and the
other sidewalk robot companies want to
keep their fleets from getting
absolutely destroyed they'll need to
focus on deploying them in areas that
already have tight security like college
campuses the list of drone delivery
robots gets a lot crazier from here but
first we need to take a moment to talk
about the human impact of automation
whenever tech companies announce new
robots everyone assumes that millions of
people are about to lose their jobs now
that certainly hasn't been the case
during previous waves of automation but
it's still worth discussing when the
automobile started replacing the horse
and carriage people started asking
questions what would happen to all the
workers who tended to the horses and
drove the carriages would we see a
massive wave of unemployment as soon as
everyone started driving themselves that
obviously didn't happen
cars took over slowly and new jobs were
created in the process
and something similar is happening with
these sidewalk robots see these college
kids wouldn't be paying for human
courier services if these robots didn't
exist they would just go pick up their
items directly this isn't a situation
where a human delivery driver is losing
a job the only person who's losing a job
is the college student who no longer has
to go pick something up and these robots
aren't even fully autonomous yet each
fleet has remote drivers that can step
in and control the units from a computer
if something goes wrong so instead of
putting people out of work this actually
creates new jobs and there's a different
sidewalk robot company named coco that
actually uses remote drivers exclusively
now i'm sure they're planning to layer
in self-driving technology down the road
but for now every robot in their fleet
is controlled by a human each sidewalk
robot company is approaching the problem
differently which is really valuable
when no one knows exactly what will work
best amazon was originally aiming for a
universal solution that could work
everywhere but it looks like a segmented
approach might be better a hospital
network will have different needs from a
college campus and this will lead to
radically different robotic solutions
and amazon is actually working on their
own sidewalk robots now so it seems like
they might wind up offering drone
delivery after all even if these drones
won't fly but all of these sidewalk
robots have one big problem they're very
slow that's great from a safety
perspective but what if you just have to
have food from a particular restaurant
that's all the way across town waiting
two hours as your delivery robot crawls
across the city at five miles per hour
doesn't exactly sound like innovation to
me well there are a few approaches that
could speed things up the most ambitious
project i found is actually inspired by
elon musk's tunneling project pipedream
labs is a startup that plans to build
delivery robots that will travel through
underground pipes this solves a few
problems while introducing a bunch of
new ones obviously with an underground
pipe you don't need to worry about bad
weather vandalism or pedestrian safety
you do however have to worry about
actually getting the pipes in the ground
the boring company obviously ran into a
lot of issues while trying to dig
massive tunnels throughout cities there
are tons of safety concerns when you're
about to drive an enormous drill right
underneath people's houses getting
governments on board with these types of
projects is incredibly difficult but
pipedream has a solution they're
planning on using standard 12-inch pvc
pipe which is already commonly used on
construction sites city workers know how
to install and maintain this type of
pipe so it's a lot easier to get
approved and instead of paying for a
massive drill to build a huge tunnel
pipe dream just needs to convince cities
to install empty pvc pipes next to the
existing water main lines once the pipes
are installed autonomous drones can
drive through these tunnels carrying
packages to their destinations because
the pipes are completely self-contained
the pods can travel 15 times faster than
a sidewalk robot it's not going to be
right for every kind of delivery but it
could be a useful option for certain
types of goods obviously tunnel based
approaches to robotic delivery take a
long time to roll out so this particular
technology is unlikely to be widely
available anytime soon but there is
still one other major option when it
comes to drone delivery and i honestly
think that this one might be right
around the corner all delivery companies
have to optimize around two factors
route density which is the number of
drop-offs you can make on a delivery
route and drop size which is the number
of parcels you can drop off at each stop
if you can make lots of deliveries in
one particular area the cost per
delivery will be low similarly if you
can drop off a bunch of packages at a
single location your cost per package
will be low the problem with most drone
delivery programs is that the drones are
designed to carry just one package and
after it drops it off the drone has to
return to a home base to recharge this
drives up the cost of delivery and
pretty soon you're better off just using
a delivery truck after all the average
ups truck makes 120 stops per day to
deliver up to a thousand individual
packages that's really hard to compete
with and that's why self-driving car
companies are starting to roll out
package delivery services cruise
automation is one of the largest
autonomous vehicle companies and
although they are primarily focused on
building a fleet of robo taxis they
recently showcased a fully autonomous
electric vehicle that can be outfitted
specifically for deliveries it might not
feel as futuristic as having a humanoid
robot knock on your door but
self-driving cars do solve a remarkable
amount of the problems faced by the
other drone delivery solutions they're
fast they work in any weather and they
can handle heavy packages but most
importantly they can optimize for route
density and drop size just like a
traditional delivery truck so back to
the original question when is drone
delivery actually going to be a reality
well if we're still using the original
amazon vision as our goal it could be a
while i think we need to update our
expectations a bit any technology that
improves the speed and efficiency of
deliveries is a win in my book and most
likely we're going to wind up with a
blend of technologies super valuable
deliveries like blood and medical
supplies will arrive through the air
while heavier stuff will continue to be
delivered on wheels we're clearly still
in the early days of robotics generally
but i think we could start seeing some
really incredible breakthroughs over the
next decade but let me know when you
think robotic delivery will actually
arrive and please check out this video
about the teslabot next it covers a
bunch of cool ai stuff that elon musk is
working on and i think you'll really
like it